Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome to the rest is history we are continuing with our world cup marathon and today dominic is morocco or mauritania as i prefer to think of it you don't you don't call morocco mauritania do you well when talking to romans okay, fair enough. So Morocco, Tom, how up with Moroccan history are you? Sort of post-Roman Moroccan history. Well, obviously it's from Morocco that the Moors invade Spain. Yep.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎来到《历史的余烬》。我们的世界杯马拉松正在继续，今天多米尼克讲的是摩洛哥，或者按我更喜欢的叫法，毛里塔尼亚。你不会——你不会把摩洛哥叫成毛里塔尼亚吧？好吧，跟罗马人说话时会这样。好吧，有道理。那么摩洛哥，汤姆，你对摩洛哥历史了解多少？类似于罗马帝国之后的摩洛哥历史。好吧，很显然，摩尔人就是从摩洛哥出发入侵西班牙的。没错。
So I know about that. Yep. And I know about the way in which once the Reconquista in Spain has been pushed back, Spanish and Portuguese forces are endlessly dipping their toes into Moroccan affairs. They are indeed. And then the French pile in, don't they? They do.
所以我知道这件事。没错。我还知道，一旦西班牙的“收复失地运动”被击退，西班牙和葡萄牙的军队就会不断插手摩洛哥事务。确实如此。然后法国人也大举介入了，对吧？他们确实介入了。
And there's all kinds of shenanigans in Tangier with various louche behaviour from the early 20th century. Kenneth Williams used to go to Morocco onco on holiday with joe wharton yeah we will not be we will not be discussing any of that that's more insalubrious end of the moroccan history spectrum um i'm happy to say so what have you what have you chosen so i have chosen an enormously important and interesting war that I think very few people know anything about, certainly in the English-speaking world. And it's called the Riff War. And it took place, Tom, this sort of high point of the Riff War was the 1920s, but it had kind of been bubbling away
20世纪初，丹吉尔还发生了各种各样的恶作剧，伴随着各种放荡的行为。肯尼斯·威廉姆斯（Kenneth Williams）以前常和乔·沃顿（Joe Wharton）一起去摩洛哥度假——对的。我们不会——我们不会讨论任何这些事，那是摩洛哥历史光谱中比较肮脏的一端，我很高兴能这么说。那么，你选了什么？所以我选了一场极其重要且有趣、但我认为几乎没有多少人了解的战争，尤其是在英语世界。它被称为里夫战争。这场战争发生于——汤姆，里夫战争的高潮时期是在20世纪20年代，但它其实已经酝酿了
since the beginning of the 20th century. It is an amazing story. And I know I've got a sort of dog in the fight here, but it's got Franco is in it. Marshall Pater is in it. There are American airmen launching bombing raids on civilians. There are chemical weapons. There are Americans. There are chemical weapons. There are sort of Islamic tribesmen. There's all kinds of stuff going on in this incredibly sort of Baroque story
自20世纪初以来。这是一个惊人的故事。我知道我在这场冲突中有一定的利益相关，但佛朗哥也卷入了其中。贝当元帅也卷入了其中。有美国飞行员对平民发动轰炸突袭。还有化学武器。有美国人。有化学武器。还有一些伊斯兰部落武装。在这个极其巴洛克风格的故事中，发生了各种各样的激烈的事件
that most people know nothing at all about. So from what you're saying, it sounds like a dummy run for quite a lot of… The 20th century. Yeah. Yeah, it absolutely is. It's both Americans launching chemical attacks and air raids and things from vietnam uh hints of the algerian war yes that's the colonial wars so in some ways it's that you could say it's the last it's the last victorian colonial war but it's also the ancestor of the spanish civil war there
而大多数人对此一无所知。所以听你这么说，这听起来像是20世纪很多……的一场彩排。是的。没错，完全是这样。这其中既有美国人发动化学攻击、空袭以及诸如此类的事情，暗示了越南战争；呃，还有对阿尔及利亚战争的隐喻——是的，即殖民战争。所以在某些方面，可以说它是最后一场维多利亚时代的殖民战争，但它也是西班牙内战的先驱，这里
are hints of the second world war and of vietnam as you say, and of the war in Afghanistan and 21st century wars. So there's loads going on. So Morocco. Morocco, as I'm sure you know, Tom, is the only North African country that was not part of the Ottoman Empire, which I actually didn't know until about an hour ago. So Morocco had and has a very long established dynasty of kind of sultans and kings. So that's the Alawi dynasty that was established in the 1630s, would you believe? However, basically what happened in the course of the 19th century
有第二次世界大战的影子，正如你所说，还有越南战争的影子，以及阿富汗战争和21世纪战争的影子。所以里面有很多东西。那么，摩洛哥。摩洛哥，我敢肯定你知道，汤姆，是唯一一个不属于奥斯曼帝国的北非国家——其实我直到大约一小时前才知道这一点。所以摩洛哥过去拥有、现在也依然拥有一个历史非常悠久的苏丹和国王王朝。这就是阿拉维王朝，据你敢不敢相信，它建立于17世纪30年代？然而，基本上在19世纪的过程中，
is that Morocco was sort of nibbled away. I mean, you were saying earlier on about the Spanish and the Portuguese. Morocco had always kind of really been prey to the sort of predators from across the straits. By the end of the 19th century, the French are established there. They have a protectorate. Also, the Spanish have two enclaves in Ceuta and Melilla, which they still have to this day on the coast,
摩洛哥遭到了蚕食。我的意思是，你刚才提到西班牙人和葡萄牙人。摩洛哥其实一直都是海峡对岸掠夺者的猎物。到了19世纪末，法国人在那里站稳了脚跟。他们建立了一个保护国。此外，西班牙人在休达和梅利利亚拥有两个飞地，直到今天，它们依然位于摩洛哥面向西班牙的地中海海岸线上，
on the Mediterranean coast of Morocco facing Spain. But now, between those two enclaves, Tom, of Ceuta and Melilla, there's a great range of mountains called the Riff. And as you will no doubt know, the people who live in those mountains, and indeed in Morocco generally, although many of them do speak Arabic, they are not Arabs. They are, of course, Berbers. They are Berbers. Yeah, they're Berbers. Exactly. So presumably they have been Berbers. I mean, they must have been Berbers forever. Yes. They've always been Berbers. They've always been Berbers. Or Numidians. In the days of the Roman Empire. So what would you call them? Numidians. Maybe Numidians. Range of name mauritanians for lots of lots of potential names so they're berbers and um so they're in these sort of very inaccessible
在地中海海岸线上。但是现在，汤姆，在休达和梅利利亚这两处飞地之间，有一片名为里夫的大山脉。毫无疑问你知道，生活在这些山脉中以及整个摩洛哥的人，尽管他们中的许多人确实说阿拉伯语，但他们不是阿拉伯人。他们当然是柏柏尔人。他们是柏柏尔人。是的，他们是柏柏尔人。没错。所以想必他们一直是柏柏尔人。我的意思是，他们从远古起就一定是柏柏尔人。是的。他们一直都是柏柏尔人。他们一直都是柏柏尔人。或者努米底亚人。在罗马帝国时期。所以你会怎么称呼他们？努米底亚人。也许是努米底亚人。有各种各样的名字——毛里塔尼亚人，有很多潜在的称呼。所以他们是柏柏尔人，呃，所以他们生活在这些非常难以接近的
mountains called the rift mountains and very few europeans at this point at the end of the 19th century had ever been into the into these mountains that's very odd isn't it considering how close they are to europe well, they're very inaccessible. They're forested. The tribes are extremely inhospitable. So a correspondent for The Times who writes about the Rift War, so we'll come to the war in due course, he tells his readers, he says very few Europeans have ever been.
被称为里夫山脉的大山里，在19世纪末这个时间点，几乎没有欧洲人曾经进入过这些山脉。这不是很奇怪吗，考虑到他们离欧洲那么近？嗯，它们非常难以接近。那里长满了森林。部落极其不友好。因此，《泰晤士报》的一位报道里夫战争的记者——我们稍后会讲到这场战争——他告诉他的读者，他说几乎没有欧洲人曾经去过那里。
The Berbers are as inhospitable to the arab as they are to the foreigner and basically if you pitch up in their country they will kill you that's basically the famous berber hospitality the famous the famed hospitality of berbers exactly so that's extraordinarily beautiful so an american correspondent called vincent sheehan who covered the war for the new york, obviously a much-loved newspaper in these quarters, Thomas, the rest is history, listeners will know. He said it reminded him of Colorado. The kind of red soil.
柏柏尔人对阿拉伯人和对外国人一样不友好，基本上如果你闯入他们的领地，他们就会杀死你。这基本上就是著名的柏柏尔式好客，柏柏尔人闻名遐迩的好客，没错。所以这真是绝妙极了。因此，有一位名叫文森特·希恩（Vincent Sheean）的美国记者，他为《纽约时报》——显然是这个圈子里备受喜爱的报纸，汤姆，《历史的余烬》的听众都会知道——报道了这场战争。他说这让他想起了科罗拉多州。那种红色的土壤。
Well, Colorado is beautiful. Colorado is a famously beautiful state. Yeah, it's got dinosaur fossils as well. There you go. I don't know if they have dinosaur fossils in Morocco. They do. Do they? Yeah.
嗯，科罗拉多很美。科罗拉多是一个以美丽著称的州。是的，那里还有恐龙化石。你看。我不知道摩洛哥有没有恐龙化石。有的。真的吗？对。
Well, I've never been to Morocco. So this, in researching this, I have developed a passionate desire to go into the, and sample this Berber hospitality for myself. So anyway, now the Spanish have their eyes at the turn of the 20th century on these mountains. The Spanish, of course, had an empire, but have largely lost it. So when King Alfonso XIII became King of Spain in 1886, they had Cuba, Puerto Rico, Guam, the Philippines, and so on. But they've lost all of those, largely thanks to the Spanish-American War at the end of the 1890s. So the Spanish are sort of feeling very bruised. And King Alfonso and the people around him form what's called the Africanist lobby. So they basically say, all the other European powers have now got these massive empires.
好吧，我从来没去过摩洛哥。所以，在研究这段历史的过程中，我产生了一种强烈的渴望，想要亲自去这些山里体验一下这种柏柏尔人的好客。无论如何，现在西班牙人在20世纪初将目光投向了这些山脉。西班牙曾经当然拥有一个帝国，但基本上已经失去了它。因此，当阿方索十三世国王于1886年成为西班牙国王时，他们还拥有古巴、波多黎各、关岛、菲律宾等等。但他们失去了所有这些，这很大程度上要归咎于19世纪90年代末的美西战争。所以西班牙人感觉受了很大的打击。国王阿方索以及他身边的人组成了所谓的“非洲主义者”游说集团。所以他们基本上说，所有其他欧洲大国现在都拥有了这些庞大的帝国，
And we, the Spanish, the great, the prototypical empire builders, we've kind of been shut out. And our destiny lies in North Africa. So the Italians are actually saying the same thing, aren't they, about Abyssinia, Ethiopia at the same time. And also the Catholic Church in Spain is also very much, you know, it's embattled by anti-clerical forces. And the Catholic Church is saying we need a new crusade.
而我们，西班牙人——伟大且最具代表性的帝国缔造者——却被排挤在外了。我们的命运在北非。所以实际上意大利人当时也在这么说，不是吗，关于阿比西尼亚和埃塞俄比亚？而且西班牙的天主教教会也极其——你知道的，它正受到反神职人员力量的围攻。天主教会在呼吁我们需要一场新的十字军东征。
So they are catching it in those terms, are they? Absolutely. So they see it as a continuation of the Reconquista. It's not finished. Because Morocco had originally been Christian. Right. We need to carry it across the seas and take back Morocco, effectively. So the Spanish have their eyes very much on these mountains
所以他们是这样看待这件事的吗？完全正确。因此，他们将其视为“收复失地运动”的延续。它还没有结束。因为摩洛哥原本是基督教国家。没错。我们需要将它跨越大海，实际上夺回摩洛哥。所以西班牙人非常渴望得到这些山脉，
in the north of Morocco. Are there any natural resources there? How do you tell me? Have you seen my notes? No. How do you know this? When Europeans are after remote mountainous regions, there's often an ulterior motive.
也就是摩洛哥北部。那里有什么自然资源吗？你怎么——告诉我。你看过我的笔记吗？没有。你怎么知道的？当欧洲人垂涎偏远山区时，通常都有不可告人的动机。
It's almost as if you've been swatting up secretly on your own in order to outflank me in my own choice of subject so yes in the rift mountains there was loads of iron there was loads of high grade iron and they can you with open pit mining techniques they can excavate it and the spanish very beautiful very beautiful but it won't be if the spanish conquer it well i gave the comparison with Colorado. Yeah. Colorado was also a huge mining place.
这简直就像是你背着我偷偷用功，以便在选题上把我比下去一样。所以是的，在里夫山脉里有大量的铁矿石，有大量的高品位铁矿石，他们可以通过露天采矿技术开采它们，而且西班牙人——非常美妙，非常美妙！但如果西班牙人征服了它，就不会美妙了。嗯，我把它比作科罗拉多。对。科罗拉多也是一个巨大的采矿地。
So the Spanish crown, they grant mining concessions to kind of rich businessmen who are close to the royal family, and they're very keen to start sort of pushing this. However, it almost from the outset goes wrong. So 1909 spanish workers who are building a big bridge which is going to bring a railway bridge which is going to open up access from the sea to these iron mines they're attacked by local berbers and the spanish mobilize their army they raise 40 000 troops and they send them in to moroc So that's the equivalent of your origins of the Vietnam War sort of moment. From that point onwards, they are kind of implicated and they're going to start throwing in more and more men
因此，西班牙王室将采矿特许权授予了那些与王室关系密切的富商，他们非常急于开始推进这项工作。然而，几乎从一开始事情就出了岔子。1909年，正在修建一座大桥的西班牙工人——这将是一座铁路桥，它将打开从海洋通往这些铁矿的通道——遭到当地柏柏尔人的袭击。西班牙人动员了他们的军队，集结了4万名部队，将他们派往摩洛哥。这相当于你所说的越南战争起源的时刻。从那时起，他们就卷入了其中，并且将投入越来越多的士兵，
in an attempt to defend these mines and railways and spread as they see it, I mean, literally, the gospel of the kind of Spanish Africanism. So there's a slight sense that the spanish have been bullied by the americans and so now they're going to go and bully the burbers somebody else yeah exactly i think there's a i think there's that's a fair that's actually a pretty fair description now right from the beginning in spain itself a lot of people are very very uneasy about this and they can see that it's going to it's going to end in disaster
试图保卫这些矿山和铁路，并正如他们所看到的——字面意思——传播那种西班牙“非洲主义”的福音。所以有一种轻微的感觉，即西班牙人被美国人欺负了，所以现在他们要去欺负柏柏尔人了？别人。对，完全是这样。我想这——我认为这是一个相当贴切的描述。现在，从一开始，西班牙国内的许多人就对此感到非常非常不安，他们能看出这将以灾难告终，
basically so when they're in 1909 when when the Spanish government starts to call up reserves, there are strikes and there are riots in places like Barcelona. In Barcelona, there's a sort of localized uprising, which becomes known as the Tragic Week, where the Catalan trade unions basically say, you know, we have no business interfering in Morocco. What's all this about? But the Spanish nevertheless are determined, the government and the king are absolutely determined to do it. And they feel, as you said, this sort of burning sense of humiliation, which they feel that they have to redress. But also in 1912 um the the french basically formally grant them a protectorate
基本上就是这样。所以在1909年，当西班牙政府开始征召预备役时，巴塞罗那等地爆发了罢工和骚乱。在巴塞罗那，爆发了一场局部的起义，后来被称为“悲惨周”，加泰罗尼亚工会基本上表示：“我们没有理由干涉摩洛哥。这到底是怎么回事？”但西班牙政府和国王仍然决心要这么做。正如你所说，他们感受到了一种强烈的羞辱感，觉得必须对此进行雪耻。而且在1912年，呃，法国人基本上正式授予他们在摩洛哥北部海岸的保护国地位，
along the northern coast of morocco so this is partly because the british were very keen to have a buffer between gibraltar and the french so it's it's good for so the british are keen on this that's very reasonable isn't it yeah but it's also well i think it's obviously completely reasonable tom but it's also because they're keen that the germans don't get in in um there have been a series of sort of um little bust-ups and crises about this and there's this sort of anxiety in the run-ups of the first world war you know we need to iron out all anomalies we need to every little last bit of the patchwork needs to be allocated to a different european power so they're not going to squabble and fall out about it so everyone knows where they stand so the spanish are now very keen to kind of formalize their protectorate and that brings them into greater problems and that raises
这部分是因为英国人非常希望在直布罗陀和法国之间有一个缓冲区。所以这有利于——因此英国人对此很热心，这很合理，不是吗？是的，但这也很——嗯，我认为这显然完全合理，汤姆，但这也是因为他们热衷于防止德国人介入，呃。此前围绕这一点已经发生了一系列的小摩擦和危机，在第一次世界大战爆发前夕，有一种焦虑情绪：“我们需要消除所有异常情况，我们需要将零碎拼图的每一小块都分配给不同的欧洲大国”，这样他们就不会为之争吵和翻脸，每个人都知道自己的立场。因此，西班牙现在非常渴望将他们的保护国地位形式化，这给他们带来了更大的麻烦，这也唤起了
the specter as it were of their great antagonist who is a really really colorful and interesting man who is a man called muhammad abdel krim now again somebody who's not really known uh now in sort of 21st century um sort of the english-speaking world but a colossally interesting figure actually tom who anticipates people like i don't know ho chi minh or or any of these kind of post-colonial or anti-colonial kind of freedom fighters but also has a slight element i suppose you could say of the mardi about him for people who remember our podcasts about general gordon so abdel krim he comes from the rift Mountains. But his father, unusually, can read and write. He's very educated, sort of intelligent.
他们的死对头的幽灵，这是一个非常非常丰富多彩且有趣的人，他是一个名叫穆罕默德·阿卜杜勒·克里姆（Mohammed Abdelkrim）的人。现在，这也是一个在21世纪的英文世界里不太为人们所知的人，但汤姆，他实际上是一个非常有意思的人物，他预示了像胡志明或者任何这些后殖民或反殖民的自由斗士这样的人物，但对于还记得我们关于戈登将军的播客的听众来说，他身上似乎也带有一点马赫迪（Mahdi）的影子。所以阿卜杜勒·克里姆，他来自里夫山脉。但不同寻常的是，他的父亲识字。他很有教养，算是很聪明。
Read and write Arabic. Arabic. And he had been officially named by the sultan as a, I don't know how to say this, Tom, you'll have to explain. Is it a Qadi? A Qadi? A Qadi. Islamic judge. Yeah.
能读写阿拉伯语。阿拉伯语。他曾被苏丹正式任命为——我不知道该怎么说，汤姆，你得解释一下。是卡迪（Qadi）吗？卡迪？卡迪。伊斯兰法官。对。
Is it a Qadi? Yeah. You sure? Yeah. You're not bluffing? Qadi. Qadi. Akadi? An Islamic judge. Akadi. Yeah. You sure? Yeah. You're not bluffing? Kadhi. Kadhi. And this guy, he had been named as an Islamic judge as Akadi by the That was beautiful Arabic pronunciation. So, Abdelkarim Sr. is a man of letters and a man of learning in his community, but he's also quite close to the Spanish. So, the Spanish have designated him what they call a moro amigo, a friendly moor. So, they rely on him as a local bigwig that they can do deals with. Thanks to his father's patronage, Mohammed Abdel Karim, he goes off to the madrasa to the university in Fez, where he studies Islamic law and he studies classical Arabic.
是卡迪吗？对。你确定吗？对。你没在虚张声势吧？卡迪。卡迪。卡迪？伊斯兰法官。卡迪。对。你确定吗？对。你没在虚张声势吧？卡迪。卡迪。而这个人，他曾被任命为伊斯兰法官，即卡迪，由……那真是优美的阿拉伯语发音。所以，老阿卜杜勒·克里姆是当地社区里的一位文人学者，但他与西班牙人的关系也相当密切。因此，西班牙人把他指定为他们所谓的“摩尔友人”（moro amigo）。所以，他们把他当作一个可以与之做交易的当地大人物来依靠。由于他父亲的庇护，穆罕默德·阿卜杜勒·克里姆前往非斯的伊斯兰学校和大学深造，在那里他学习了伊斯兰法律和古典阿拉伯语。
But he also has these links to the Spanish. So because of that, his father was able to get him a job teaching at a primary school in Melilla in the Spanish enclave. So he's got links to the Spanish and he obviously, you know, presumably can speak a little bit of Spanish and has contacts with the Spanish authorities and so on. They hire him to write articles in Arabic for a newspaper in the enclave in Melilla. And there he pours out all these articles saying European civilization is great. spanish are our friends they are bringing technology and sort of civilization that will elevate the people of morocco and all this kind of business and he indeed ends up working very closely with a an organization called the native affairs office
但他与西班牙人也有这些联系。正因如此，他的父亲得以帮他在西班牙飞地梅利利亚的一所小学找到了一份教书的工作。所以他与西班牙人有联系，并且显而易见——想必能说一点西班牙语，与西班牙当局有接触等等。他们雇他在梅利利亚飞地的一家报纸上用阿拉伯语写文章。在文章中，他倾注了所有这些观点，称欧洲文明是伟大的，西班牙人是我们的朋友，他们正在带来技术和文明，这将提升摩洛哥人民的福祉，以及所有诸如此类的事情。他甚至最终与一个名为“土著事务办公室”的组织进行了非常紧密的合作。
so he's working with the army he's working with a kind of civil bureaucracy he's absolutely implicated and in fact muham-Karim, so this is Abdul-Karim Jr., he is designated eventually, in I think 1913, the chief Islamic judge in Melilla. So he's basically the person that the Spanish have identified as a really promising collaborator in their colonial enterprise. And then it's really hard to sort of work out exactly what it is, but something goes wrong. And this is actually, what's so interesting about this is that this is not really unusual. Quite often, people who end up becoming anti-colonial freedom fighters have originally been collaborators who have since fallen out
所以他为军队工作，为某种民事官僚机构工作，他完全深度参与其中。事实上，穆罕默德·阿卜杜勒·克里姆——也就是小阿卜杜勒·克里姆——最终在我想是1913年被任命为梅利利亚的首席伊斯兰法官。所以他基本上是西班牙人在他们的殖民事业中认定的一位极具前途的合作者。然后，很难确切弄清楚究竟发生了什么，但有些事情出了岔子。实际上，这其中最有趣的是，这其实并不罕见。很多最终成为反殖民自由斗士的人，最初都是合作者，后来与盟友闹翻了，
with their allies and who feel let down and cheated but because of their previous collaboration they have the the contacts the articulacy yeah the kind of resources if you like that will enable them to become the standard bearers of the rebellion and that's exactly what happens with Abdel Krim. He and his father, it seems, had got close to the Germans. Now, Spain was very neutral in World War I. And I think what clearly had happened is that they had some kind of links with the Germans. The Spanish authorities found out about it and punished them much more severely than they were expecting. So they thought they were bending the rules, but the Spanish thought they had kind of broken them. So the Spanish actually jail Abdelkrim very briefly. This is the junior.
他们感到被抛弃和欺骗，但由于他们先前的合作经历，他们拥有了人脉、出色的口才——是的——还有各种资源，这些都使他们能够成为叛乱的旗手。而这正是阿卜杜勒·克里姆身上发生的事情。据推测，他和他的父亲曾与德国人走得很近。现在，西班牙在第一次世界大战中是完全中立的。我认为显然发生的事情是，他们与德国人有某种联系。西班牙当局发现了这一点，并对他们进行了远超他们预期的严厉惩罚。所以他们以为自己只是打了个擦边球，但西班牙人认为他们已经越界了。因此，西班牙人实际上将阿卜杜勒·克里姆短暂地投进了监狱。这是小阿卜杜勒·克里姆。
The junior. And although he then gets his judgeship back after he comes out of prison, he's been completely humiliated in the eyes of kind of his community and stuff. And the Spanish are sort of you know the spanish i think don't realize how much they have offended him and humiliated him so that's quite odd isn't it because the spanish are all about honor as well yes but i don't think i think as you'll find in this podcast the spanish handle the affairs of morocco in an unbelievably incompetent and insensitive way. And that's clearly what they did with the Abdelkrim family. I think what was also happening was that clearly as they were expanding the mines into the mountains and things,
小阿卜杜勒·克里姆。尽管他出狱后恢复了法官职务，但在他的社区等人眼中，他已经彻底受辱了。而且西班牙人——我认为西班牙人没有意识到他们对他的冒犯和羞辱有多深。这不是很奇怪吗，因为西班牙人不是很讲究荣誉吗？是的，但我认为——正如你在这期播客中会发现的那样，西班牙人处理摩洛哥事务的方式简直不可思议地无能且麻木不仁。这显然就是他们对待阿卜杜勒·克里姆家族的方式。我认为同时发生的还有，很显然，随着他们将矿山扩展到山里等地，
they were putting his father and the rest of the family in a kind of position where they were increasingly going to have to choose between continuing to back the Spanish. And, you know, if they did that, they would alienate a lot of the local community or they would have to side with the local community and therefore lose the Spanish. And probably they choose the only option that's really open to them, which is they have to go with the people
他们把他的父亲和家里的其他人置于这样一种境地：他们越来越不得不在继续支持西班牙人——如果他们这样做，就会疏远许多当地社区——或者站在当地社区一边从而失去西班牙人之间做出选择。他们可能选择了对他们来说唯一可行的选项，那就是他们必须与周围的人站在一起，也就是当地社区。因此，非常明显的是，到了1920年左右，作为山里大家族的阿卜杜勒·克里姆家族——有很多人对他们负有一种部落忠诚——已经切断了与西班牙当局的联系。穆罕默德·阿卜杜勒·克里姆站了出来，
who live around them, i.e. the local community. So what is very clear is that by about 1920, the Abdelkrim family, who are a big family in these mountains, so a lot of people kind of owe them a kind of tribal loyalty, they have severed their connections with the Spanish authorities. And Mohammed Abdelkrim sort of steps forward protect the sort of the villages of the mountains against what he sees as the the cruel and sensitive intrusions of spanish modernity is there an element of defending islam as well because that's a theme isn't it of the the merging of nationalist and islamic exactly. Exactly, yes. I think that's a really, really astute observation. I mean, that Reconquista element, that kind of Catholic Crusader man,
保护山村免受他眼中西班牙现代性残酷而麻木不仁的入侵。这里面是否也有保卫伊斯兰教的成分？因为那也是一个主题，不是吗？民族主义与伊斯兰教的结合。完全正确。是的，我认为这是一个非常非常敏锐的观察。我的意思是，“收复失地运动”的成分，那种天主教十字军战士的姿态，
that's clearly not going to go down well with lots of people in Morocco. But the Berber tribes had famously been very disputatious and had been sort of renowned for their feuds among one another and really the only way in a pre-nationalist age an age when a lot of people can't read and write so they're not susceptible to the kind of what you might say the classic kind of forms of nationalism islam is the obvious glue i mean you see that everywhere in the 20th century don't you in the anti-colonial world and so as you say i mean
显然无法在摩洛哥的许多人那里吃得开。但柏柏尔部落向来以好斗著称，并以彼此之间的世仇而闻名。在“前民族主义”时代，在这个许多人目不识丁、因此无法接受你可能会说的经典形式的民族主义的时代，伊斯兰教是显而易见的凝聚剂。我的意思是，你在20th世纪的反殖民世界里到处都能看到这一点，不是吗？正如你所说，我的意思是，
there's there's discussions of the mardi for instance yeah are very interested in that question exactly exactly so so that's what makes abdul krim such an interesting figure because in some ways he looks back to the mardi but in other ways he obviously looks further forward you know to the to later 20th and 21st century century kind of Islamic insurgencies. Because he starts to use, I think increasingly, Islam as the glue to bind together what would otherwise be a kind of feuding, very sort of quarrelsome Berber confederation. So he recruits Berber riflemen, they basically they're very good riflemen you know that sort of stereotype of the sort of the tribesmen who can shoot a I don't know what do they shoot him
有关于马赫迪的讨论，等等——是的，对这个问题非常感兴趣。完全正确，完全正确。所以这就是为什么阿卜杜勒·克里姆是一个如此有趣的人物。在某些方面，他回溯到马赫迪，但在其他方面，他显然向前看，看向了后来的20th和21st世纪的某种伊斯兰叛乱。因为他开始越来越多地使用伊斯兰教作为胶水，将原本形同散沙、争吵不休的柏柏尔人联盟粘合在一起。所以他招募柏柏尔步枪手，他们基本上是非常优秀的步枪手——你知道那种部落民的刻板印象，他们可以用枪击中——我不知道，他们射击什么？
or what would you shoot him uh the tip of a cheroot a tip of yeah the tip of a colonel's cheroot exactly from a distance of 10 miles or whatever exactly I think this is I mean this is top historical analysis but I think that's exactly what the Berbers are able to do. Now, by contrast, the Spanish army in North Africa, and I should apologize at this point to any Spanish, I don't think we really have any Spanish listeners, do we? Do we have Spanish listeners? Yeah, I think we do.
或者你会用枪射击什么？呃，雪茄烟蒂，一颗雪茄的烟蒂——是的，上校雪茄的烟蒂，从10英里外的距离，等等。我认为这——这是顶级的历史分析，但我认为这正是柏柏尔人能够做到的。相比之下，西班牙驻北非军队——我此时应该向任何西班牙人道歉，我想我们大概没有真正的西班牙听众吧？我们有西班牙听众吗？是的，我想我们有的。
Well, they should probably avert their, can you avert your ears? They should close their ears at this point. Lock their ears. Because their army is in absolute shambles it's a it's a terrible shambles so their army is is incompetent there are tens of thousands of them but they're incredibly corruptly led most of them they too are illiterate actually they're illiterate conscripts they're from the very poorest part of spanish society they're given rifles that don't work or rifles that are sort of 50 years old they are given they're incredibly badly treated by their officers so they sort of are given coffee and beans to to sort of live on and in fact they end up a lot of them end up actually bartering
好吧，他们大概应该把耳朵——你能把耳朵捂上吗？他们此刻应该闭上耳朵。锁上耳朵。因为他们的军队简直是一团糟，这是一场可怕的混乱。他们的军队无能至极，有几万人，但他们的领导层极其腐败。大多数人其实也是文盲，他们是不识字的应征入伍者，来自西班牙社会最底层。他们发到的步枪是坏的，或者是用了50年的老旧步枪。他们的军官对他们极其恶劣，所以他们只能靠咖啡和豆子勉强度日。事实上，他们中的许多人最后甚至在柏柏尔村庄里用
their rifles in berber villages in exchange for fresh vegetables which obviously isn't ideal is it um they don't have toilets in their barracks it's all sort of it's just all inept and sort of shambolic they're also accompanied by this giant, I don't really know how to put it in a... Well, the mind's boggling. Caterpillar? No. It's a giant horde of prostitutes, Tom. Okay. Okay.
手中的步枪去巴特换取新鲜蔬菜，这显然不太理想，不是吗？呃，他们的军营里没有厕所，一切都乱七八糟、杂乱无章。随军的还有一支庞大的——我真不知道该怎么用一个词来表达……嗯，真让人匪夷所思。毛毛虫？不。那是庞大的妓女大军，汤姆。好吧。好吧。
I think that reflects very well on my imagination that that wasn't what I... Yeah, I suppose people would now object to the word horde and prostitutes, so they'd say, I don't know, sex workers. Yeah. Anyway, there's a load of them. Put us. There's a small army of them yeah of court of top spanish courtesans who who accompany the army through the mountains so venereal disease in the army is rampant so basically one in every two men
我觉得这很能体现我的想象力，那不是我想象的……是的，我想现在人们会反对“妓女”这个词，所以他们会说，我不知道，性工作者。不管怎样，那里有一大群人。随军妓女。那里有一支由顶级西班牙名妓组成的小军队，他们伴随着军队穿过群山，因此军中的性病泛滥成灾。基本上每两个士兵中就有一个
or whatever is crippled by venereal disease proud record so the the the officers are are universally agreed by foreign war correspondents to be atrocious uh as one do they have anything going for them well one american journalist said of the spanish officers he spent he said they spent their time gambling and whoring and molesting the native moorish women so that doesn't suggest no you know that's not a proud record. And their chief officer is a man called General Manuel Fernandez Silvestre. And he's the commander in Ceuta and Melilla in the two enclaves. Now he is a veteran of the Spanish-American war in Cuba. So he knows the sting of humiliation. He's determined to put it right. I mean, you'll be pleased to hear Tom, because you're looking for positives. He is a tremendous womanizer.
或者无论多少人被性病摧残——值得骄傲的纪录。因此，军官们被外国战地记者一致认为极其恶劣——正如一位记者所说，他们把时间都花在了赌博、嫖娼和骚扰当地的摩尔妇女上。这可不说明——你知道的，这不是什么值得骄傲的纪录。他们的最高指挥官是一个名叫曼努埃尔·费尔南德斯·西尔韦斯特雷（Manuel Fernandez Silvestre）将军的人。他是休达和梅利利亚两个飞地的指挥官。他是一位古巴美西战争的老兵。所以他深知耻辱的滋味。他决心雪耻。我的意思是，你会很高兴听到这个，汤姆，因为你在寻找积极的一面。他是一个极其风流的女性追求者。
Well, I would expect nothing less. I read in a biography of him online that he, quote, fathered scores of illegitimate children by the various women he seduced. So he's very fecund, I think it's fair to say. Okay, yeah. And he's a very flamboyant figure, sort of mustaches and all this kind of thing. But he has distinctly, I don't know, how would I put this? He has non-guardian-friendly approach to interactions with the locals. So the Minister of War says to him at one point, have you got all the equipment you know do you have everything you need you need anything else and he says yeah i do the only way to succeed in
好吧，我对此不抱其他期望。我在网上一篇关于他的传记中读到，他“通过诱奸多名女性，留下了数十名私生子”。所以我认为公平地说，他非常多产。好吧，是的。他是一个非常浮夸的人物，留着小胡子之类的。但他有着明显的——我不知道，我该怎么说呢？他对当地人的互动方式很不符合“监护人友好型”（guardian-friendly）。所以战争大臣曾在某个时刻对他说：“你拥有所有装备了吗？你知道的，你有一切需要的东西吗？你还需要别的什么吗？”他回答说：“是的，我有。在摩洛哥成功的唯一方法，”他说，“就是砍下所有摩尔人的脑袋。”
morocco he says is to cut off the heads of all the moors so so that's a very traditional approach yeah it's not hearts and minds no it's not hearts and minds so he's he's very much harking back basically to the 10th century there definitely he is and in fact at some stage abdel krim who is holed up in the mountains sends him a message and says don't come out of your enclaves into the mountain with your army into the mountains don't cross this particular river if you do you will die and general fernandez silvestre says to the spanish press say well what, what do you think of this? And he says, this man, Abdelkrim, is crazy. I'm not going to take seriously the threats of a little Berber judge whom I had at my mercy a short time ago.
所以这是一种非常传统的方法。是的，这不是“赢得民心”。不，这不是“赢得民心”。所以他基本上是在倒退回10世纪，绝对是的。事实上，在某个阶段，躲在山里的阿卜杜勒·克里姆给他带了个信，说：“不要带着你的军队从飞地里出来进山，不要过这条特定的河。如果你这么做了，你就会死。”而曼努埃尔·费尔南德斯·西尔韦斯特雷将军对西班牙媒体说：“嗯，你们怎么看这事？”他说：“这个人，阿卜杜勒·克里姆，疯了。我不会把一个不久前还在我脚下求饶的柏柏尔小法官的威胁当回事。
His insolence merits a new punishment. Now, you can probably guess at this stage where the story of these two men is heading. I can. This is not going to, in fact in fact end i'll tell you now as a massive spoiler alert general fernandez silvestro is not going to cut off the head of abdel krim quite the reverse right so he sent out his army into the mountains i shouldn't laugh actually it's a terrible story he sends his army into the mountains they spit up and they start
他的无礼理应受到新的惩罚。”现在，在这个阶段，你大概可以猜到这两个人的故事走向了。我能猜到。这不会——事实上，我作为巨大的剧透现在就告诉你，曼努埃尔·费尔南德斯·西尔韦斯特雷将军并没有砍下阿卜杜勒·克里姆的头，恰恰相反。所以他把军队派进了山里——其实我不该笑，这是一个糟糕的故事。他把军队派进了山里，他们分散开来，开始
going to all these little forts and these things called block hours which are these sort of mini forts that they've established in the mountains quite quickly they all get cut off from each other their communications are terrible they start to send relief expeditions to some of these forts but they're all absolutely they're destroyed by the sharpshooting yesbers. Yes, the cheroots are hanging all over the rift mountains. And the men who are in the forts, they've got no supplies, so they drink, first of all, ink, and then they're drinking their own urine. Right.
前往所有这些小堡垒以及被称为“块式堡垒”（blockhouse）的东西，这些是他们在山里建立的微型堡垒。很快，它们都彼此孤立了，通讯糟透了。他们开始向其中一些堡垒派遣救援远征队，但它们全都被那些神枪手歼灭了——是的。是的，雪茄烟蒂挂满了整个里夫山脉。堡垒里的士兵们没有任何物资，所以他们先是喝墨水，然后喝自己的尿。对。
Which is, you know, that's always a bad sign. Never a good position to be in. General Fernando Silvestro, after a deal of sort of marching about he ends up in a fort in a place called annual so it's literally spelt like the word annual and um at this stage he's conscious that something has gone wrong they've got cut off from the coast the the mountains are kind of crawling with berbers uh he's lost communication with some of these other forts this is all a bit of a disaster. So he's walking around on the sort of parapet of this fort, and he can see movement out in the
你知道，这总是一个不祥之兆。绝不是一个好处境。曼努埃尔·费尔南德斯·西尔韦斯特雷将军在四处行军折腾了一番之后，最终来到了一个名为阿努阿尔（Annual）地方的堡垒——它的拼写字面意思就像英文的“annual（年度的）”一样。在这个阶段，他意识到有些事情出问题了。他们与海岸的通讯被切断了，山里到处都是柏柏尔人，他与其中一些其他堡垒失去了联系，这一切简直是一场灾难。所以他在这个堡垒的护墙上走来走去，他能看到山丘上有人在移动。
hills. He's chewing his moustache the whole time, and supposedly is just sort of muttering gibberish to himself. So his officers don't really know what to do. So this is very apocalypse now then isn't it it's very apocalypse now and then in july 1921 general um fernandez silvestre decides okay i've had enough we're going to march out of this fort and we're just going to make a break for it and head to the coast and he says to his men and and the colossal legion of prostitutes that are with them that have come with them ludicrously he says we're out you know we're on our way off you go throw open the gates of the fort and off you go so they they march out and they basically march out and what happens is that the rift tribesmen just shoot them
他一直在嚼着自己的小胡子，据说只是在嘴里嘟囔着一些胡话。所以他的军官们根本不知道该怎么办。这非常像《现代启示录》，不是吗？这非常像《现代启示录》。然后在1921年7月，曼努埃尔·费尔南德斯·西尔韦斯特雷将军决定：“好吧，我受够了，我们要撤出这个堡垒，我们要强行突围前往海岸。”他对他的手下以及与他们同行的庞大妓女大军说——荒谬的是，他说道：“我们要撤了，出发吧，打开堡垒的大门，你们走吧。”于是他们行军出击，基本上就是开拔撤退，而发生的事情是，里夫部落武装就从山岗上像打靶一样
all like from the hills as though they're in people describe it they say it's like this shooting gallery people are just sort of trudging along, being shot down. Including the prostitutes. Including the prostitutes. So they're all shot down. I think 13,000 people. Quite like the first Afghan war, that kind of situation. It's absolutely like that. When the British try to leave Kabul and get wiped out.
把他们全部射杀。人们形容说，这就像一个射击场，人们只是艰难地挪动着脚步，然后被逐个击毙。包括妓女在内。包括妓女在内。所以他们全都被射杀了。我想有13,000人丧生。这很像第一次阿富汗战争那种情况。完全是那样。就像英国人试图撤出喀布尔却全军覆没一样。
But with, I think, an extra sort of degree of Baroque flamboyance. A magical realist spin yeah exactly exactly because they all turn into butterflies or because the general you see tom he has not marched out this is the thing they've marched out but he's there on the parapet and he and the last sighting of him people say they stood he was standing there on the power back, chewing his moustache and shouting at his men down below, run, run, the bogeyman is coming. Which is not a detail that you would expect. And he stands there shouting that while they're all being shot down.
但带有某种额外的巴洛克式的华丽浮夸。带有魔幻现实主义的转折。对，完全是这样。因为他们全都变成了蝴蝶，或者因为将军——你看，汤姆，他没有行军撤退，这就是关键所在。他们是撤退了，但他还在护墙上。最后一次有人看见他时，人们说他站在护墙上，
They're all killed. And then he goes inside and back down into his tent, shoots himself in the head. And that's the end of General Fernandez Silvestvestre so the bogeyman has come the bogeyman has come would that be a good moment to take a break it would i think it's fair to say for the spanish this has not been a good 20 minutes tom okay well uh let's see if it improves for the spanish uh after the break i i have no idea what's going to happen dominic i don't know what's going to happen. Although you have mentioned that chemicals appear. Yes.
嚼着胡子，对下面的手下大喊：“快跑，快跑，大灰狼要来了！”这可不是你会预料到的细节。他就站在那儿大喊，而所有人都在被射杀。他们全都被杀了。然后他走进室内，回到自己的帐篷里，朝自己头上开了一枪。曼努埃尔·费尔南德斯·西尔韦斯特雷将军的故事就这样结束了。所以大灰狼真的来了。大灰狼真的来了。现在是不是休息一下的好时机？是的。我想公平地说，对西班牙人来说，过去的20分钟可不算美好，汤姆。好吧，让我们看看在休息之后，西班牙人的情况是否会有所改善——我不知道会发生什么，多米尼克，我不知道会发生什么。尽管你提到过化学品会出现。是的。
I'm suspecting that things are going to get worse in all kinds of ways. We will see you in a few minutes. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
我怀疑事情会以各种方式变得更糟糕。我们几分钟后再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back to our world cup special on morocco we are looking at the riff wars and dominic before the break you were making this sound increasingly like a particularly bloody
评论以及少量演艺圈八卦节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们已经成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票，请访问 th
magical realist novel the spanish general has just shot himself the bogeyman has come yeah are more terrible things in the offing they are yes, yes. So this is the greatest defeat. Spain has not had a great run in recent years, it's fair to say. Obviously, the defeat in Cuba, the loss of the Philippines and so on. So the Spanish are feeling sore anyway, but this is undoubtedly the most humiliating defeat in Spanish history. So they've lost 13,000 men and indeed that sort of small battalion of ladies of the night have also been lost. There is a tremendous amount of sort of soul searching and sort of angst ridden breast beating in Spanish politics. Now the king, Alfonso XIII, who was a huge sort of mover, as I said in the first half in the sort of campaign in morocco he is pretty unrepentant so he has told the news in in very spanish monarchy fashion he has told the news
魔幻现实主义小说中，西班牙将军刚刚自杀了，妖怪来了，是的，还有更可怕的事情即将来临吗？是的，是的。所以这是最大的失败。平心而论，西班牙近年来运气一直不太好。很明显，在古巴的战败、失去菲律宾等等。所以西班牙人本来就感到很痛心，但这无疑是西班牙历史上最耻辱的失败。所以他们损失了13,000人，甚至那一小队风尘女子也不幸遇难。西班牙政坛上充斥着大量的深刻反思和焦虑不安的捶胸顿足。现在国王阿方索十三世，他是正如我在上半场中所说的摩洛哥战役的主要推动者之一，他毫无悔意，所以他以非常典型的西班牙君主制方式向新闻界透露了这一消息，他向新闻界透露了消息
while playing golf in the south of france and someone comes up to him and says your majesty we've lost the entire army 13 000 men are dead dead and the king says, do you know what he says Tom? There is time to beat the Berbers yet and win the game, something like that No he says I shouldn't laugh actually he says
当时他正在法国南南部打高尔夫球，有人走过来对他说，陛下，我们全军覆没，13,000人阵亡了，阵亡了。国王说，汤姆，你知道他说什么吗？还有时间击败柏柏尔人并赢得比赛，诸如此类的话。不，他说，其实我不该笑，他说
chicken meat is cheap Oh God Wow, that's terrible what a thing to say, so he's saying that of his own army yeah i mean anyway chicken meat is cheap very very unlike very unlike the behavior of our own late queen very very she wouldn't say things like that would she she definitely would not if we lost an army in similar circumstances so um i don't think i don't think the king would say that now would he tom no he wouldn't i don't think the king of spain now, would he, Tom? No, he wouldn't. I don't think the king of Spain would say that now, to be fair.
鸡肉很便宜。哦，天哪，哇，这太糟糕了，怎么能说这种话呢？所以他是在说他自己的军队吗？是的，我的意思是，无论如何，鸡肉很便宜。这非常非常不像我们已故女王的行为，非常非常不像，她不会说那样的话吧？如果我们曾在类似情况下失去了一支军队，她绝对不会这么说。所以嗯，我觉得国王不会那样说，对吧，汤姆？不，他不会的。我觉得现在的西班牙国王不会那样说，对吧，汤姆？不，他不会的。说实话，我觉得现在的西班牙国王不会那样说。
No. Maybe his predecessor. Well, his dad might. Playing golf in Saudi Arabia. Anyway, listen, we're spiralling off into abuse of the Spanish royal vermin. This is not what we're about. We haven't been true to our values there, Tom. So, yes, the Spanish then start to raise a new army.
不。也许他的前任会。好吧，他爸爸可能会。在沙特阿拉伯打高尔夫球。不管怎样，听着，我们开始滑向对西班牙王室败类的辱骂了。这不是我们的风格。汤姆，我们刚才违背了我们的价值观。所以，是的，西班牙人随后开始组建新军队。
There are lots more sort of strikes and there are mutinies people don't want to go in barcelona crowds burn spanish flags and in fact wave the flag of the of the riff because you know they they identify with the the moroccans more than they do with their own monarchy i mean it's an absolute sort of shambles, really. All of that is the prelude to a coup in Spain. So a general, Miguel Primo de Rivera, so if any of our listeners know about the Spanish Civil War, they will know that the name Primo de Rivera, particularly his son,
还有更多类型的罢工和哗变，人们不想去，巴塞罗那的群众焚烧西班牙国旗，实际上还挥舞着里夫人的国旗，因为你知道他们认同摩洛哥人多于认同他们自己的君主制我的意思是这真是一团糟。所有这一切都是西班牙政变的前奏。所以一位将军，米格尔·普里莫·德里维拉，如果我们的听众中有人了解西班牙内战，他们就会知道普里莫·德里维拉这个名字，尤其是他的儿子，
plays a big part in the lead-up to the Spanish Civil War. And this is the point in which General Primo de Rivera seizes power. And one reason for doing that is actually because parliamentary parties wanted to launch an investigation to what had gone wrong in the Battle of Anuel. And people were worried that it would implicate the king, as well as the army high command. So the king is still in power despite this coup? Yes, he is still in power, Tom. So it's a little bit like the situation in Italy, where you have Mussolini becoming dictator, but the king is still there. So in Spain,
在西班牙内战爆发前夕扮演了重要角色。这也是里维拉将军夺取政权的节点。他这么做的一个原因其实是，议会各党派想要对阿努尔战役中究竟出了什么问题展开调查。人们担心这会牵连到国王以及军队的高层指挥官。所以尽管发生了这场政变，国王仍然在位？是的，他依然在位，汤姆。所以这有点像意大利的情况，墨索里尼成了独裁者，但国王还在。所以在西班牙，
Primo de Rivera is dictator, but with the acquiescence of the king. And how much power does the king have? Not much power, really. I mean, in truth, particularly once power has passed to the army. He's there as a figurehead, but he pretty much agrees with everything the army is doing, to be completely honest with you so at first the new spanish strongman prima de rivera he says well we need to pull back a bit so they pull back you know let's stop throwing sort of men away without working out a proper strategy so they pull back to their enclaves of suita and melilla and that basically leaves abdel krim as the master of the of the mountains as the of the unchallenged master of the rift so he sets up then something called it's an unrecognized state
普里莫·德里维拉是独裁者，但得到了国王的默许。那国王有多少权力呢？其实没多少权力。我的意思是，说实话，特别是当权力已经移交给了军队之后。他只是作为一个名义上的领袖存在，但完全说实话的话，他几乎同意军队正在做的每一件事。所以起初，西班牙的新强人普里莫·德里维拉说，嗯，我们需要稍微撤退一下，于是他们撤退了，你知道的，别再无谓地消耗士兵却不制定一个合适的战略了，所以他们撤退到了休达和梅利利亚的据点，这基本上就让阿卜杜勒·克里姆成为了山区的统治者，成为了里夫地区无可争议的主权者。于是他建立了一个被称为——这是一个未被承认的国家——
called the republic of the rift and they do things like they they start building roads he has a little bureaucracy and he institutes an islamic legal code so you were saying in the first half about islam yeah islam is obviously what you go to if you are trying to nation build because that's the way of bringing all the different tribes and the different clans and things together that's all you have work because the berbers are a proud independent people i think it does work actually who resent the yoke of authority it does work because it because they have an an external enemy against whom they can unite in fact they have two france and spain so you know a nation building is always most successful i would say when you have an enemy you know when you have an antagonist and they have knuckled down and they
叫做里夫共和国，他们做一些诸如开始修建道路的事情，他有一小套官僚机构，并建立了一套伊斯兰法律体系。所以你刚才在前半段提到关于伊斯兰教的事情，是的，如果你正试图进行国家建设，伊斯兰教显然是你的首选，因为那是将所有不同的部族、不同的氏族等等凝聚在一起的方法，这就是你所有的全部工作，因为柏柏尔人是一个自豪而独立的民族。我认为这确实行之有效，他们怨恨权威的枷锁。它确实管用，因为因为他们有一个共同的外敌，他们可以团结起来对抗这个外敌，事实上他们有两个敌人：法国和西班牙。所以你知道，国家建设总是最成功的，我想说，当你有一个敌人时，当你有一个对立面时，他们低头顺从了，他们
they become loyal loyal members of the republic of the rift well i think we're perhaps exaggerating that a bit because the republic of the rift doesn't really last that long so it's not like these structures have time to sort of to embed themselves because the Spanish are planning the whole time to sort of get it back they have they have various ways of doing it so so I said at the beginning that this would anticipate the Spanish civil war which it absolutely does because the forces on which the Spanish come to rely completely anticipate the Spanish civil war so the first thing is that they start to raise, basically, a Moroccan army. So this is what becomes the Army of Africa that Franco famously commands in the 1930s.
他们成为了里夫共和国忠诚的、忠诚的成员。好吧，我想我们可能有点夸大其词了，因为里夫共和国其实并没有持续那么久。所以这些结构并没有时间去慢慢嵌入其中，因为西班牙人一直在计划着如何把它夺回来。他们有各种各样的方法来做到这一点。所以——所以我一开始就说过，这将预示着西班牙内战，事实也确实如此，因为西班牙人所依赖的那些力量完全预示了西班牙内战。所以首先，他们开始招募一支基本上是摩洛哥人的军队。这就是后来弗朗哥在20世纪30年代指挥的著名的非洲军团。
So they're called the regulares, regular units, and they have Spanish officers, but they're kind of Moroccan infantrymen, I guess. And the other thing is they start to create their own foreign legion you know the french foreign legion the spanish have a foreign legion too and still do and is it organized on the same format that anyone can join and yeah i think pretty much although a lot of the people who join it actually are Spanish rather than sort of charismatic. Old Herovians. Yeah, old Herovians. Pelford things from Nanny.
所以他们被称为正则军，即正规部队，他们有西班牙军官，但我想他们基本上是摩洛哥步兵。另一件事是，他们开始创建自己的外籍军团。你知道法国外籍军团，西班牙也有一个外籍军团，而且现在依然有。它是按那种任何人都可以加入的模式组织的吗？是的，我想基本上是这样的，尽管加入其中的很多人其实是西班牙人，而不是那种极具魅力的人物。老校友。是的，老校友。保姆照顾长大的那种贵族。
Exactly. Who've been wrongly accused of cheating at school. Yes. Or something. Have to win their honor back. Yeah, exactly. I don't think there's as much of that in the Spanish Foreign Legion, to be honest. So the bloke who leads the Spanish Foreign Legion, to be honest. So the bloke who leads the Spanish Foreign Legion
没错。在学校被错误指控作弊的人。是的。或者类似的事情。必须赢回他们的荣誉。对，完全正确。说实话，我觉得西班牙外籍军团里没那么多这种人。所以，率领西班牙外籍军团的那个家伙——说实话，率领西班牙外籍军团的那个家伙——
is an interesting character. He's a guy called Lieutenant Colonel José Milian Astray. And he is a very entertaining man. He's completely demented. You astonish me. So he had been wounded in Morocco in the arm and also in the eye, so very Nelsonian. So he wears an eye patch, of course by law the leader of the spanish foreign legion really needs to do yeah so he and his and his um
是一个很有意思的人物。他叫何塞·米兰·阿斯特雷中校。他是一个非常有趣的人。他完全疯了。你可真让我大吃一惊。他在摩洛哥作战时手臂和眼睛都受了伤，非常像纳尔逊。所以他戴着眼罩，当然，作为西班牙外籍军团的领袖，按理说确实需要戴眼罩。所以他和他的——他的嗯
he wears eye patch and white gloves uh to hide his sort of his um his injuries and he's known as Glorioso Mutilado, the Glorious Mutilated One. Which I think is, again, exactly what you would, what you want, isn't it? I mean, from... Yeah, and as you said, I mean, you could apply that
他戴着眼罩和白手套，以此来掩盖他的——他的伤势，他被称为“光荣的残疾人”（Glorioso Mutilado）。我认为，这同样也是你梦寐以求的，不是吗？我是说，从……是的，正如你所说，我的意思是，你可以把这个词用在
to Nelson, couldn't you? You could, although Nelson didn't. So, you know, his motto that he says, that is still, I think, the motto of the Spanish Foreign Legion.
纳尔逊身上，对吧？你可以的，尽管纳尔逊没有。所以，你知道，他的座右铭，就是他说的那个，我想至今仍然是西班牙外籍军团的座右铭。
Viva la muerte. Long live death. Yes. I mean, that's very Rider the Reheren, isn't it Viva la muerte. Long live death. Yes. I mean, that's very Ride of the Reheren, isn't it? Actually, when you think about it. So, and you see, to go back to what you were talking about in the first half, the Spanish Foreign Legion is absolutely founded on Reconquista principles. So when people are sort of inaugurated into the Legion in the 1920s,
“胜利属于死亡”（Viva la muerte）。万岁，死亡。是的。我的意思是，这非常符合“里海骑兵”的风格，不是吗？“胜利属于死亡”。万岁，死亡。是的。我的意思是，当你仔细想想，这非常符合“里海骑兵”的风格。所以，你看，回到你前半部分所谈论的内容，西班牙外籍军团完全是建立在“收复失地运动”的原则之上的。因此，当人们在20世纪20年代加入军团时，
they are kind of steeped in a world of kind of Christian crusading. Templars, the Knights Templar, that kind of thing. Yeah, all the imagery is we are kind of crusaders who are carrying the gospel against these sort of these Muslim hordes and all this kind of thing. So Mian Astray is the head of the Spanish Foreign Legion with his eyepatch, and he needs a number two who does not wear an eyepatch, but is a bit more sort of like a bureaucrat who will sort of be his organizer and stuff. And this man is a young captain, well, originally a captain, who ends up being promoted to major and so on and so forth,
他们可以说是沉浸在一个充满基督教十字军东征的世界里。圣殿骑士团，圣殿骑士，诸如此类。是的，所有的意象都在宣示：我们是十字军，我们带着福音去对抗那些穆斯林游牧部落，诸如此类的话。所以，米兰·阿斯特雷戴着眼罩担任西班牙外籍军团的负责人，他需要一个副手，这个副手不能戴眼罩，而要更像一个官僚，能够充当他的组织者之类角色的人。这个人是一个年轻的队长——最初是队长，最后晋升为少校等等等等——
whose name is Francisco Franco. I was wondering. So this is where Franco enters the story. Now, Franco also has an interesting... So Franco is from Galicia in the north of Spain. He had been fighting in Morocco for years, as had Mier Estre. And Franco, with his sort of Moroccan troops, had been attacked and shot in the hills near Ceuta.
他的名字叫弗朗西斯科·弗朗哥。我正纳闷呢。所以弗朗哥就是在这里登场了。现在，弗朗哥也有一个有趣的……所以弗朗哥来自西班牙北部的加利西亚。他在摩洛哥作战多年，米兰·阿斯特雷也是。弗朗哥带着他的摩洛哥部队，在休达附近的山里遭到袭击并中弹。
And there, he'd been hit by bullets in the abdomen. And his Moroccan troops thought he was going to die, but he didn't. And so they said he must be blessed. He must be protected by God. And that sort of sense of Franco as this kind of, you know, he's the chosen one. I mean, this is obviously going to be part of Franco's personal mythology because Franco is, I think it's fair to say, an absolutely terrible man and not in any way a sort of a friend of the rest is history. But this sort of idea of him being chosen by God
在那里，他的腹部被子弹击中了。他的摩洛哥部队以为他要死了，但他没有死。因此他们说他一定是有神灵保佑。他一定受到了上帝的庇护。这种把弗朗哥视为什么某种——你知道的，他就是天选之子的感觉。我的意思是，这显然将成为弗朗哥个人神话的一部分，因为我认为可以公正地说，弗朗哥是一个绝对糟糕透顶的人，绝不是什么《历史的其余部分》节目的朋友。但这种他被上帝选中的想法——
as a crusaderader all of that stuff that plays an enormous part in the ideology of the nationalists and that must help win hearts and minds in morocco what he's been chosen by god yeah and he's leading a band of crusaders they must love that in the republic of the rift well his no i'm sure they don't love it at all but his but that's sort of that his troops definitely think that he has something, a special quality. You know, they, well, actually, do they? Or is that, how much is that Franco myth-making? I don't know enough of the details of this to know how much this is a product of Franco's later propaganda.
作为一个十字军战士，所有这些都在民族主义者的意识形态中发挥了巨大的作用，这一定有助于赢得摩洛哥的人心，因为他被上帝选中了？是的，他正率领着一支十字军，里夫共和国的人民一定很喜欢这一点吧。好吧，不，我确信他们一点也不喜欢，但是——但是他的部队绝对认为他拥有某种特殊品质。你知道的，他们——嗯，事实上，他们真的这么认为吗？还是说，这在多大程度上是弗朗哥的神话塑造？我对其中的细节了解不够，不知道这在多大程度上是弗朗哥后来宣传的产物。
But it'd be interesting if listeners do know if they can tell us. So the Spanish have got new troops. They also have new weapons. And I mentioned this at the beginning that there were going to be chemical weapons. So obviously people have used chemical weapons in World War I, but they have been outlawed. So they're outlawed in 1925 in the Geneva Protocol. But the Spanish are completely shameless. So even though they signed the Geneva Protocol, they have every intention of using them. Their war minister says,
但如果听众们知道的话，能告诉我们就好了，这会很有趣。所以西班牙人有了新军队。他们也有了新武器。我一开始就提到过，他们会使用化学武器。所以显然人们在第一次世界大战中曾使用过化学武器，但它们已经被取缔了。所以在1925年的《日内瓦议定书》中，它们被禁用了。但西班牙人完全不知羞耻。所以尽管他们签署了《日内瓦议定书》，他们却完全打算使用它们。他们的战争大臣说：
Until now, I have been obstinately resistant to the use of suffocating gases against indigenous peoples. But after what they have done, and after their treacherous and deceptive conduct, I will use them with true joy. Lovely thing to say. Lovely, lovely, lovely chat. So they use phosgene, dip diphosgene nitrochloroform
直到现在，我一直顽固地反对对土著人民使用窒息性气体。但在他们做出了这些行径之后，在他们背信弃义和欺骗性的行为之后，我将带着真正的喜悦使用它们。多可爱的一句话啊。真可爱、可爱、可爱的聊天。所以他们使用了光气、双光气、氯化硝基甲烷、
mustard gas and are they dropping this from planes i think most of it's from shells rather like in um in world war one yeah yeah i mean as you know tom science is not really my strong point and i would never claim to be an expert on munitions but but basically they're applying the lessons of the first world war exactly to the colonial the colonial dimension they're getting help from french intelligence so french intelligence helps them to to to get this sort of weapons systems and german companies so basically it's a European effort. So is this because the humiliation of the Spanish by the Republic of the Rift is seen as a humiliation not just for Spain, but for European empires generally? Yeah, I think that's right. I think the French have
芥子气，他们是从飞机上投掷这些东西吗？我想大部分是从炮弹里发射的，就像在……在一战中那样。对，对，我的意思是，如你所知，汤姆，科学其实不是我的强项，我也绝不敢自称是军火专家，但基本上他们是将第一次世界大战的经验教训直接应用到了殖民地维度上。他们得到了法国情报部门的帮助，所以法国情报部门帮助他们获得了这种武器系统，还有德国公司，所以基本上这是一项全欧洲的努力。那么，这是因为西班牙人被里夫共和国羞辱，不仅被视为对西班牙的羞辱，而且被视为对欧洲帝国的普遍羞辱吗？是的，我认为是这样的。我认为法国人
their protectorate in Morocco. The French are very alarmed by all this sort of the spanish shambles um and crucially i think the big the big turning point actually i think and abdel krim's big mistake is that he sends his troops into across the border into the french bit so the french are much more organized than the spanish um he has been getting supplies and things from across the border anyway from the cities you know in the french protectorate the french are sort of beginning to to stamp on that a little bit and to shut it down and at that point he sends some of his sort of um his raiding parties in to attack the french. They actually overcome, they storm some French forts and things. They actually kill about, or wound about 6,000 French soldiers.
在摩洛哥有他们的保护国。法国人对这场西班牙式的混乱感到非常惊恐，嗯，最关键的是，我认为最大的转折点其实是——我认为阿卜杜勒·克里姆最大的错误在于，他将部队派过了边界，进入了法国控制区。所以法国人比西班牙人组织得严密得多；无论如何，他一直通过边界从城市（你知道的，在法国保护国境内）获得补给和物资，法国人正开始对此进行一点点打击并试图将其切断。就在那个时候，他派遣了一些——嗯——他的突击队去袭击法国人。他们实际上攻克并突袭了一些法国堡垒之类的地方。他们实际上杀死或打伤了大约6,000名法国士兵。
And this is, to him, I suppose he thinks he has no choice. But once he's poked the French, they're not going to take that lightly. So once the French are involved, he really is up against it. And the French, they bring in their top man, actually.
对于他来说，这——我想他觉得自己别无选择。但既然他招惹了法国人，他们是不会轻易罢休的。所以一旦法国人卷入其中，他可就真的陷入绝境了。而法国人，他们派出了他们最顶尖的人物。
Marshal Petain, is it? hero of verdun he is the absolute you know saintly heroic crusader of france who had who had seen off the germans in the french imagination so they bring in um peter the french and the spanish meet in the summer of 1925 and they say okay we you know let's crush this guy once and for all so you've got peter you've got franco you've got the glorious, glorioso mutilado, they're all involved. But what you also have, you have two other innovations which point to World War II. So number one is you have aerial bombings. So you have, I think this is an extraordinary thing. A guy called Charles Sweeney, who was an American World War I pilot, he gets in touch with the French and he says, I would love to raise a squadron of American volunteers to come and fight for you.
贝当元帅，对吧？凡尔登的英雄。他绝对是法国人心目中那位圣人般的英雄十字军，在法国人的想象中，正是他击退了德国人。所以他们派出了——嗯——贝当。法国人和西班牙人在1925年夏天会面，他们说，好吧，我们——你知道的，让我们彻底粉碎这家伙。所以你有贝当，你有弗朗哥，你有荣耀的——“光荣的残疾人”，他们都卷入了其中。但与此同时，你还有另外两个指向第二次世界大战的创新。第一点是，你有了空中轰炸。所以你有了——我认为这是一件非凡的事情。一个名叫查尔斯·斯威尼的人，他曾是一名美国的一战飞行员，他联系了法国人，并说：我很想招募一个由美国志愿者组成的中队来为你们战斗。
And this is a very common 1920s thing. People who, I mean, you could, it's sort of Bulldog Drummond or it's the Black and Tans or it's the Fry Corps. Or Donatio. Sorry? Or Donatio. sorry exactly people who basically won't let the great war go and charles sweeney is one of those people he misses the adventure and the excitement and you know killing people and he says let's come and you know let's come and do some air raids for you so they he does raise a squadron of several i think a couple of dozen um american pilots they have seven bombers and they fly off these bombers. And the most famous bombing they do is of a town called Sheffshowan,
这是20世纪20年代非常普遍的现象。人们，我的意思是，你可以——这有点像“德拉蒙德斗牛犬”（Bulldog Drummond），或者是“黑棕军团”（Black and Tans），或者是“自由军团”（Freikorps）。或者唐纳蒂奥。不好意思？或者唐纳蒂奥。抱歉，完全正确。那些基本上无法让世界大战过去的人，查尔斯·斯威尼就是其中之一。他怀念那种冒险和刺激，还有你知道的，杀戮的快感，他说：让我们来——你知道的，让我们来为你们进行一些空袭吧。所以他确实招募了一个由好几个——我想大概有二十来个——美国飞行员组成的中队，他们有七架轰炸机，他们驾驶着这些轰炸机起飞。他们实施的最著名的轰炸是一个叫舍夫沙万的小镇，
which I think is now a very popular tourist destination, a kind of blue city or something in the mountains. And they bomb it. One of the first aerial bombardments of a civilian town. So it's often said in the First World War that it's a process of colonial wars being brought back to the imperial metropoles. Yeah. And could you say that the Rift War
我想现在那里是一个非常热门的旅游目的地，山里的一座蓝色城市什么的。他们轰炸了它。这是人类历史上对平民城镇的首次空中轰炸之一。所以人们经常说，在第一次世界大战中，这是一个将殖民地战争带回帝国本土的过程。是的。那么你是否可以说，里夫战争
has that relationship to the Second World War, perhaps? Oh, yeah. I like that, Tom. I thought you were going to turn it around and say that this is the Great War being applied to the colonial periphery. I suppose it kind of is. Which it kind of is. But you're right. They are, well, they are experimenting with techniques.
与第二次世界大战也有这种关系呢？哦，是的。我喜欢这个说法，汤姆。我还以为你要反过来说，这是将大战的经验应用到了殖民地边缘地带呢。我想它在某种程度上确实是这样的。它在某种程度上确实如此。但你是对的。他们正在——好吧，他们确实在试验各种技术。
Yeah. Yes. What happens in the Riff is going to happen, say, to Guernica. And then it's a new course to Coventry and to Hamburg. Exactly. to hamburgers exactly what happens in the riff is going to happen to spain in the 1930s and then as you say um to all europe in the 1940s interestingly one thing about um the colonial dimension charles sweeney is completely open about the racial element to this so he says he's asked why they're volunteering to help the french and the sp. And he says, in our view,
是的。里夫战争中发生的事情将会发生在，比如说，格尔尼卡。然后它又转移到了考文垂和汉堡。一点也没错。转移到了汉堡。里夫战争中发生的事情将会发生在20世纪30年代的西班牙，然后正如你所说，嗯，在20世纪40年代降临到整个欧洲。有趣的是，关于殖民地维度的某一点，查尔斯·斯威尼对其中的种族因素毫不掩饰。所以当被问及他们为什么要自愿帮助法西斯和西班牙时，他说，在我们看来，
France in fighting Abdelkrim is fighting the cause of the white man's civilization. And all of us who have formed this squadron know enough of the world to appreciate what the white man's civilization means. Right, so not Christian civilization. This is a racialized... Yes, I suppose he would say there was no, I mean, of course, I'm sure Charles Sweeney would say there was no contradiction between those two things, but you're absolutely right that there were different dimensions to this. One is racial, one is the sort of the Christian thing. I mean, he's not going to be stirred by talk of the Reconquista, is he? I suppose.
法国在与阿卜杜勒·克里姆的战斗中，是在为白人文明的事业而战。我们这些组建了这个中队的人，对世界有足够的了解，能够欣赏白人文明意味着什么。好吧，所以不是基督教文明。这是一个被种族化了的……是的，我想他会说，没有——我的意思是，当然，我确信查尔斯·斯威尼会说这两者之间没有任何矛盾，但你是绝对正确的，这里面有不同的维度。一个是种族的维度，另一个是那种基督教的东西。我的意思是，他不会被关于“收复失地运动”的言论所激起波澜，对吧？我想是的。
So that's one, the aerial bombing. I can't tell you, by the way, some listeners were wondering how many people were killed. And the truth is, I don't tell you, by the way, some listeners are wondering how many people were killed. And the truth is, I don't know, because so little is written about this. It's so little known. I mean, I'd love for people who do know to tell us. But also, we should put our hands up and say the British are doing the same in Iraq at this time, aren't they? Well, tear gas.
所以这是一个空中轰炸。顺便告诉你们，我无法告诉大家，一些听众想知道到底死了多少人。而事实是，我无法告诉你，顺便说一句，一些听众想知道到底死了多少人。而事实是，我不知道，因为关于这方面的记载实在太少了。它实在太不为人知了。我的意思是，我希望那些知道的人能告诉我们。但同时，我们也应该举手承认，英国人在同一时期也在伊拉克做着同样的事情，不是吗？嗯，催泪弹。
But they're doing aerial bombings. They are doing aerial bombings. They're doing aerial bombings i mean they're kind of doing aerial bombings they're using aerial bombings to control colonial populations so it's yeah it's not just this is yet more evidence of your unsavory but i i think you know i i i think it's important for our occasional sallies into patriotism that we yeah we acknowledge the worse so then we can enjoy this podcast is over we need to urgently call a podcast strategy meeting to discuss your um your answer anyway listen the other thing i think we need to say is that um the other big innovation this is the first d-day the first sort of amphibious landing your brother would get very excited by this tom he
但他们在进行空中轰炸。他们在进行空中轰炸。他们在进行空中轰炸——我的意思是，他们某种程度上在进行空中轰炸，他们利用空中轰炸来控制殖民地人口，所以——是的，这不过是你那些不光彩行为的又一个证据。但我认为，你知道的——我认为，在我们偶尔进行爱国主义出征时，承认这些黑暗面是很重要的，这样当这个播客结束时，我们就可以享受——我们需要紧急召开一个播客战略会议来讨论你的——你的回答。不管怎样，听着，我认为我们需要说的另一件事是，嗯，另一个重大创新，这是第一次D日登陆，第一次两栖登陆，你兄弟会对这个感到非常兴奋，汤姆，他
loves an amphibious so the french and the Spanish, they have a big meeting and they say, we're going to do an amphibious landing. Why? Just for the fun of it. I don't actually know why they did it. Why are they doing it? I mean, they've got these ports. I think because they need to, there's a particular point they can only get to
太喜欢两栖登陆了。所以法国人和西班牙人举行了一场盛大的会议，他们说，我们要进行一次两栖登陆。为什么？只是为了好玩吗？我其实不知道他们为什么要这么做。他们为什么要这么做？我的意思是，他们已经有这些港口了。我想是因为他们需要——有一个特殊的地方，他们只能
from the sea maybe. Okay. A place called Al-Hussemas Bay. And if they can do this landing at al-hussemas bay they don't need to trudge through the mountains and they have so that basically on september the 8th 1925 a landmark in military history tom the french they the sort of two things happen at once one 20 000 french troops march north out of their protectorate into the mountains. And secondly, the Spanish land 18,000 men by sea so that it's absolutely D-Day scenes.
从海上抵达，也许吧。好吧。一个叫做阿尔胡塞马湾的地方。如果他们能在阿尔胡塞马湾进行这次登陆，他们就不需要在山地中跋涉了，于是——基本上在1925年9月8日，军事史上的一个里程碑，汤姆，法国人——差不多两件事同时发生：一方面，2万名法国士兵北出保护国，开进山区。其次，西班牙人通过海路运送了18,000名士兵登陆，这绝对是D日的场景。
The operation has been postponed because of bad weather, just like D-Day was, and then they do it. They have thousands of men in landing craft. They land artillery. They land tanks. They have air support from more than 100 planes, they have cruisers offshore kind of bombing the Berbers, they have an aircraft carrier from which they're launching all these kind of sorties. The supreme commander of the operation is the dictator himself,
这次行动因为恶劣天气而推迟了，就像D日一样，然后他们行动了。他们有成千上万的人乘坐登陆艇。他们登陆了大炮。他们登陆了坦克。他们有来自100多架飞机的空中支援，他们有离岸巡洋舰轰炸柏柏尔人，他们有一艘航空母舰，从上面起飞所有这些类别的战斗机。这次行动的最高指挥官就是独裁者本人，
Primo de Rivera. But the commander on the ground is a man who will, I'll come back to right at the end. He's called Jose Sanjurjo. And he's going to be a big figure in the Spanish Civil War. But the man who leads the first wave of troops ashore at Al-Husayna. Do you know who that is, Tom? Pablo Picasso. Salvador Dali. Brilliant. I'm working my way through. Yeah, yeah. Famousali. Brilliant.
普里莫·德里维拉。但地面的指挥官是一个人，我会在最后再回到他身上。他叫何塞·桑胡霍。他将成为西班牙内战中的一个重要人物。但率领第一批部队在阿尔胡塞马湾登陆的人——你知道那是谁吗，汤姆？巴勃罗·毕加索。萨尔瓦多·达利。太棒了。我正在一个个排除。对，对。著名的达利。太棒了。
I'm working my way through. Yeah, yeah. Favourite Spaniards. I'm afraid it's Franco. It's Franco again. Disappointing. Somebody we've already encountered. I've really let you down there.
我正在一个个排除。对，对。最喜欢的西班牙人。恐怕是弗朗哥。又是弗朗哥。令人失望。我们已经遇到过的人。我真的让你失望了。
I over-egged it, and it would have been better if it was Picasso. Improbable. As your father makes it. Implausible. Picasso had a colourful life, though. So anyway, when all these landings have taken place, Abdelkrim eventually knows the game is up. There's no way that he can beat the Spanish and the French simultaneously.
我把牛皮吹破了，要是毕加索的话会更好。难以置信。正如你父亲所说的那样。不可思议。不过毕加索确实过着丰富多彩的生活。总之，当所有这些登陆完成后，阿卜杜勒·克里姆最终知道大势已去了。他绝无可能同时击败西班牙人和法国人。
His home is occupied, his home village. The Spanish and the French sort of, they basically carve their way through the mountains. And he knows he's doomed. So he surrenders, tellingly, not to the spanish but to the french and they basically promise him that they will allow him and his family they will protect take him and his family into custody but protect them as long as he surrenders unconditionally and he does this the french actually don't treat him terribly badly so So he surrenders in 1926.
他的家园被占领了，他的家乡村庄也是。西班牙人和法国人一路——他们基本上在群山中杀出了一条血路。他知道自己完了。所以他投降了，意味深长的是，他不是向西班牙人投降，而是向法国人投降，而法国人基本上向他保证，他们会允许他和他的家人——他们会把他和他的家人带入羁押保护之中，但只要他无条件投降，就会保护他们，而他确实这样做了。法国人其实对他不算太差——所以他于1926年投降了。
He's taken off to Réunion, which is in the Indian Ocean. Sort of very bone apart. It could be worse. It could be Devil's Island. Right. He's taken off there. He's actually treated pretty well. He and his family lived there in a kind of gilded exile for about 20 years.
他被带到了位于印度洋的留尼汪岛。非常有拿破仑的风格。情况可能更糟。可以是被流放到魔鬼岛。没错。他被带到了那里。他其实得到了相当不错的对待。他和他的家人在那里过着某种镀金的流亡生活，大约有20年之久。
So this is like the British removing the king of Ashanti. Exactly. Ashanti. Exactly. exactly yeah to the seychelles and he stays there for about 20 years and then in 1947 uh he says he wants to go to to france for health reasons he needs health care because he's quite an old man by this point and the french say fine yeah you can go to france and they go off by by ship but um when they get to egypt they stop in egypt and the ship is is raided by moroccan nationalists who um take them off and hide them in cairo and this is apparently against abdelkrim's wishes because the french kind of lined him up a nice house in the south of france yeah yeah but but he's told no no no no you have to stay in cairo become an icon of the rebellion but now the the moroccans wanted him to come back to morocco but he refused he said he would never go back to morocco while there were still french and spanish enclaves in morocco and
所以这就像英国人流放阿散蒂国王一样。没错。阿散蒂。完全正确，是的——流放到塞舌耳。他在那里呆了大约20年，然后在1947年，嗯，他说他想出于健康原因去法国。他需要医疗保健，因为这时候他已经是个相当老的老头了，法国人说，行吧，你可以去法国。于是他们乘船出发，但是——当他们到达埃及时，他们在埃及停留，这艘船遭到了一群摩洛哥民族主义者的袭击，他们把他带下船，把他藏在了开罗。这显然违背了阿卜杜勒·克里姆的意愿，因为法国人本在法国南部为他安排好了一栋漂亮的房子——对的，对的——但是有人告诉他，不，不，不，你必须留在开罗，成为叛乱的象征。但现在，摩洛哥人希望他回到摩洛哥，但他拒绝了。他说，只要摩洛哥境内还存在法国和西班牙的飞地，他就绝不回摩洛哥，
he never did so he died in cairo in 1963 gosh goodness so he got taken in 1947 and he died in Cairo in 1963. Gosh, goodness. So he got taken in 1947 and he died in 1963. Yeah, so 16 years he had to live in Cairo against his will. Well, why couldn't he go on to France? He might have been under guard. I don't know. Chained to a radiator. I don't think he was chained to a radiator. I think maybe he thought that if he went to France,
他也确实从未回去。所以他于1963年在开罗去世。天哪，真是惊人。所以他在1947年被抓走，并在1963年死于开罗。天哪，真是惊人。所以他在1947年被抓走，并在1963年去世。是的，所以在开罗，他违心地生活了16年。好吧，为什么他不能去法国呢？他可能受到监视。我不知道。被锁在散热器上？我不认为他被锁在散热器上。我想也许他认为如果他去了法国，
I mean, he couldn't have gone to France once he'd been rescued. No, I suppose not. That would look like a terrible... Yeah. If he sort of put out a public statement saying, I was looking forward to the golf courses of the river. Fair enough. But anyway, so that's the end of the Rift Walkers.
我的意思是，他一旦被营救出来，就不能再去法国了。不，我想也是。那看起来会糟糕透顶……是的。如果他发表公开声明说，我一直很期待里维拉的高尔夫球场。好吧，也对。不管怎样，这就是里夫战争的结局。
Obviously, the Spanish and the French won. They divided up Morocco between them. The Spanish lost about 43,000 troops killed, missing, and wounded. The French lost about 18,000. The Berbers, it's impossible to say, maybe 10,000, maybe 20,000, hard to tell. Historians now look back at that war and they say, is it the last colonial war? Is it the first anti-colonial war? Is it an ancestor of the Spanish Civil War, of world war ii um well the one thing that is very clear is that where where it definitely prefigures the span the horrors of the spanish civil war is it's incredibly savage and violent so it's full of massacres and tortures and beheadings the the
显然，西班牙人和法国人赢了。他们瓜分了摩洛哥。西班牙损失了大约43,000名阵亡、失踪和受伤的士兵。法国损失了大约18,000人。柏柏尔人方面，具体数字无法统计，也许10,000人，也许20,000人，很难说。历史学家现在回看那场战争，他们会问：这是最后一场殖民地战争吗？这是第一场反殖民战争吗？它是西班牙内战、第二次世界大战的祖先吗？嗯，非常明显的一点是，它在哪些方面绝对预示了西班牙内战的恐怖——那就是它极其残酷和暴力，到处都是大屠杀、酷刑和斩首，
spanish army i think sort of motivated in part by their sense of humiliation, behave pretty badly throughout. kind of reactionary sort of mindset, where they're always conscious, thinking that they're being betrayed by politicians, and where they think only extreme violence. You know, that sort of, we must cut the heads off all the moors. That sort of attitude becomes very, very widespread among the officers. Exterminate all the brutes. Exactly that, exactly that. So if you look at the people, Tom,
西班牙军队——我认为在某种程度上是由他们的羞辱感所驱动的——在整个过程中表现得相当糟糕。那种反动的心态，他们总是带着自我意识，认为自己被政客背叛了，并且认为只有极端暴力才是出路。你知道的，那种“我们必须砍掉所有摩尔人的头”的态度。这种态度在军官当中变得非常非常普遍。消灭所有野蛮人。正是如此，完全如此。所以如果你看看那些人，汤姆，
who were the key figures in planning the rebellion in 1936 that launched the Spanish Civil War, the overall head of the whole thing, Emilio Mola, he had been wounded in the Rift War himself. The guy who I told you planned the amphibious operation at Al-Husayn, so that's Jose Sanjujo, he was called the Lion of the Rift and he was made Marquess of the Riff. He's going to be one of the chief Spanish commanders in the Spanish Civil War. He dies in a plane crash. Mola, the other big Gs, he died in a car crash. And that meant that the number three man ended up becoming the face of the Nationalist Rebellion. And that's Franco, who was then commander of the Army of Africa. So in many ways, you can trace the whole of the nationalist rebellion and that's Franco who was then commander of the army of
他们是1936年发动西班牙内战的叛乱策划者的核心人物，整个事件的总负责人埃米利奥·莫拉，他自己就在里夫战争中受过伤。我刚才告诉过你策划阿尔胡塞马湾两栖登陆的那个人——也就是何塞·桑胡霍，他被称为“里夫之狮”，并被封为里夫侯爵。他将成为西班牙内战中西班牙国民军的主力指挥官之一。他在一次空难中丧生。莫拉，另一位大佬，死于车祸。这意味着三号人物最终成了国民军叛乱的门面。那就是弗朗哥，他当时是非洲军团的司令。所以在很多方面，你可以将整个国民军的叛乱——那就是弗朗哥，他当时是
Africa so in many ways you can trace the whole of the Spanish civil war back to what happened in Morocco in the 1910s and 1920s this extraordinary chapter of history blood-soaked chapter which anticipated so many of the the horrors to come brilliant Dominic very a very cheery story well we're all about yeah we're all about we're all about cheer um yeah that's that's quite a grim story um and actually serves as a good introduction to the episodes on the spanish civil war that i'm sure we will be doing we'll definitely do a series on the spanish war tom if only because we've had so many kind remarks for our Iberian accents that we did in our series about Portugal. My Spanish accent is better than my Portuguese.
非洲军团的司令——所以在很多方面，你可以将整个西班牙内战追溯到20世纪10年代和20年代发生在摩洛哥的事情，这段非凡的历史，血迹斑斑的历史，它预示了未来如此多的恐怖。太精彩了，多米尼克，这是一个非常欢快的故事。好吧，我们全员——是的，我们全员都在——我们全员都在追求欢乐——好吧，那是一个相当严峻的故事——实际上它很好地起到了介绍西班牙内战各集的作用，我确信我们会做这个内容的。我们肯定会做一系列关于西班牙内战的节目，汤姆，如果仅仅是因为我们在关于葡萄牙的系列节目中模仿伊比利亚口音得到了那么多的赞美。我的西班牙语口音比我的葡萄牙语口音好。
Is it? Oh, I cannot wait. That is a positive. Let's do the whole thing in Spanish. I think people would love that. But actually, you know what we should do? I think we should do something about Marrakesh or Fez or some of these great sort of Moroccan cities at some point. You know what we should do something about Marrakesh or Fez or some of these great sort of Moroccan cities at some point.
是吗？哦，我简直迫不及待了。这可真是个积极的信号。我们用西班牙语录制整个节目吧。我想人们会很喜欢的。但实际上，你知道我们应该做什么吗？我觉得我们在某个时候应该做一些关于马拉喀什、非斯或者其中某些伟大的摩洛哥城市的内容。你知道我们应该做一些关于马拉喀什、非斯或者其中某些伟大的摩洛哥城市的内容。
Yeah, we should do one of your walking tours of the soups of Marrakesh. We should go to Tangiers. Go to Tangiers. What's so great about Tangiers? Because it's such an interesting place, isn't it? Because it was a League of Nations protectorate. So it's kind of neutral city. And so it's got of neutral city and so it's it's got that slight west berlin feel it's got
是的，我们应该做一期你带领下的马拉喀什露天市场徒步之旅。我们应该去丹吉尔。去丹吉尔。丹吉尔有什么好的？因为它是一个如此有趣的地方，不是吗？因为它曾是一个国际联盟托管地。所以它算是一个中立城市。因此它拥有——它拥有那种微微的西柏林氛围，它拥有
that it's it's a place where full of um you know it's we talked at the beginning kind of great writers um it's a kind of great center for gay culture uh it's it's a really really interesting okay really interesting place and it's and it's very beautiful and it appeared in uh the living daylights timothy dalton's first well there you. Well, there you go, John. It's something for everyone. So I think I'd love to do that. Yeah. And we will definitely be back. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community,
那种——那是一个充满——你知道的，我们一开始谈到的那种伟大的作家——它是一个同性恋文化的伟大中心，它是一个非常非常有趣的地方——真的很有趣的地方，而且它非常美丽，它曾出现在《黎明生机》里，提摩西·道尔顿的第一部……好吧，你看。好吧，你看，约翰。这里面有适合每个人的东西。所以我想我很乐意去做那个。是的。我们绝对会回来的。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及优先购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。